the US government's biggest financial
asset is student loan debt and I mean
big time like over 1.1 trillion it says
the value of federally backed student
loans held by the government has risen
by more than a
th% since the last recession and now
tops at 1.1 trillion student loans make
up
45% 45% it says we hear a lot about
government debt but what we don't hear
about are government assets and so we're
looking at this and the Federal Reserves
Financial account data found that the
student loans make up the largest
financial asset held by the federal
government by a huge margin so I say all
that to say if we're waiting around for
the government to do something in the
way of maybe not making loans maybe
forgiving your loans anything that's
going to cause this to not be an asset I
think that we're going to be waiting
until the cows come home is basically
what I'm saying hell's basically going
to have to freeze over